The joe rogan experience and they got imprisoned and they had a lot of
resentment towards Kennedy.
I mean,
I go into the book though a little bit about the Kennedy assassination and the
belief that a lot of that,
a handful of those Cubans may have been involved in the Kennedy assassination
along with the Italians with the mob because they were working hand in hand with
the CIA.
Yeah.
That was one of the leading conspiracies outside of the CIA killing him and even
the CIA killing him was a part of the bay of the Bay of pigs conspiracy.
Yeah,
and also the,
the idea that he wanted to disband the CIA.
There was a really interesting article recently and there was dismissing almost
every single conspiracy theory about the Kennedy assassination.
They said,
except the CIA one,
there's legitimate possibilities that the CIA,
well,
you can bet your ass that if the CIA was involved in Cubans or some in the book
you speak about Fidel's mistress.
Yeah.
That he got this one too with her at this particular one Margarita.
She had gone to New Orleans.
Yeah.
Or The Dallas.
My retail.
Lorena,
this is very interesting.
The tortillas figure.
She had a child with him and had an abortion and didn't have the child.
She got pregnant with fidelity.
In fact,
Castro,
we admitted as much.
She got pregnant with Castro.
She had,
she had an abortion and then the CIA used her to try to assassinate Castro.
Um,
she had was supposed to slip him a pill and she put it in her,
um,
face cream and the pill dissolved in her face cream and that was the pill she
was going to try to slip to Castro.
Her,
her case agent was a guy named Frank Sturgis who wound up being one of the
Watergate burglars.
See the thing about Bay of Pigs and the Cubans,
uh,
the Bay of Pigs invasion is the key to understanding the whole ladder part of
the 20th century politics in the United States.
The Cold War because the alliance between the CIA and the Cubans rears its head
constantly throughout the latter part of the 20th century.
The Watergate burglary,
five out of seven of the burglars were Cubans,
Bay of pigs veterans.
They had been recruited by a guy named he Howard Hunt Cih and who is one of the
orchestrators of the Bay of Pigs invasion was also one of the people that on his
deathbed said that he was involved in the assassination of Kennedy.
Yes.
This,
so the CIA would come to these Cuban exiles,
the militant exiles,
and they'd say,
go to this operation,
go do this burglary at the,
at the Watergate.
And then we go get Fidel,
go do this assassination.
And then we go get Fidel.
And the Cubans were always ready and willing because it was all leading back to
getting,
it was all leading back to,
did you ever see the images of a,
what they said was he Howard hunt?
It was one of the people that was arrested.
There was a series of,
um,
uh,
there was a bunch of guys that were arrested,
that were on trains that were calling them.
Hobos were all very well dressed.
Right.
That were near where the grassy knoll woman on the grass and all,
yeah.
Oh,
there's lots of rumors about that,
that he,
Howard hunt was one of those men.
There was even a reference that Jose Miguel battle was one of those men,
but that couldn't have been the case because he was in the army at the time.
Uh,
the U s army,
um,
no,
so,
so it's like a,
it's like a subterranean narrative that runs through the latter part of the 20th
century,
the CIA and right wing elements in American politics using the Cuban Americans
to do all kinds of dirty covert deeds.
And we're talking about terrorist activity.
Uh,
assassination of an ambassador from Chile,
right in Washington DC blew up his car cause he was sympathetic to Castro,
a bomb planted on a Cuban,
a jetliner flying from Panama City to advantage 73 people killed innocent
people,
including the fencing team from Cuba,
young people,
a dirty war,
a dirty war was waged by the anti-castro underground,
uh,
in combination in partnership with the CIA.
And we know about it now because a lot of it has been declassified and it's come
out,
we didn't know about it at the time it was taking place.
Why they blow up the plane.
Just an act of terrorism against Cuba to,
uh,
to,
show them that it could be done to instill fear and paranoia in the queue.
The,
the concept was to destabilize the Cuban government so they'd be vulnerable and
then you could take them over.
So any,
any act against Cuba.
I mean,
asking why blowing up the plane wood is asking like,
why fly planes into the World Trade Center?
You know,
it was just a destructive act.
It's pretty amazing how resilient Castro was.
I mean,
unbelievable.
The guy's 90 miles away from Miami and just ran shit through the 60s,
the 70s,
the 80s,
the 90s and to the 2000 they say there was something like 632 known plots over
over the course of four or five decades to kill Castro.
Incredible.
632 that seemed to happen.
It'll be 101 ways to kill Fidel.
Yeah.
And he went to,
he got a little train in New York and they're like,
are you fucking crazy?
And they checked to see the other bulletproof vest on.
He's like,
no,
he took the train to the UN.
Wow.
Like he's fucking nuts.
Yeah.
He was fucking nuts.
So,
so,
um,
what makes this,
this gangster story of the corporation so interesting and different is this
political context,
the framework that all this shit was taking place against the backdrop of this
desire to kill Castro and take back,
take back the homeland and anyone who was involved in that was seen as a hero
within the community.
Joey can tell you about that.
Union city,
New Jersey and Miami where the hot beds of the anti-castro movement there were,
where it was an organization and union city called Omega seven and there was one
in Miami called Alpha 66.
These were terror organizations,
secret organizations that existed to plant bombs.
They would plant bombs at embassies in the United,
you know,
in New York City.
They would put,
they would put bombs at Lincoln Center when a,
when a,
when an orchestra from Cuba was making an appearance,
they were trying to shut down any relationship between the US and Cuba and
governments that were sympathetic to Cuba.
They would,
they would do actions against them.
And this went on for like 40 years.
Man,
that's unbelievable.
You couldn't mention for dome the Seventies in Union city like a joke.
Like it's not a joke.
Don't even,
don't even know.
Don't even bring them up dog,
cause you will get smacked.
Now was there any pro Fidel support amongst Cubans?
There was and bad things would happen to them.
Um,
in the United States,
yes.
You Go.
What about in Cuba?
Pro Castro,
India.
Oh yeah,
sure.
I mean,
um,
was it real or was it out of fear?
It's real.
I mean,
I've been there numerous times.
You know,
the killing people made a choice,
uh,
and the revolution I believe would have happened with or without Fidel Castro.
I'm the guy who was in power.
Battista had taken over the government and the coup d'etat,
he wasn't elected,
so he was kind of a fraudulent president.
And there was an,
ever since he got in,
people knew he was a fraudulent president and there was attempts to try to
foster him.
And that's why he was such a dictator.
He knew they wanted the house to him.
So he used the military to repress any kind of movement against him and it was
ugly and the people rose up against it.
That's what happened.
It wasn't so in,
in my belief,
the revolution in Cuba happened for a very legitimate reason.
After it happened in power,
it was revealed that Castro and Che Guevara were communists.
He Castro was very cagey about that during the revolution.
They never talked about Marxism and being communists or any of that.
And in fact,
Fidel came to union city,
came to the United States to raise money for the revolution while it was going
on.
Got Arrested in union city.
My friend's mom,
the escalate,
he says,
she says,
she still remembers taking the bus in the morning and union city and Fidelis
talking to her on the way.
I'm talking to you.
How you doing,
Susan?
What's going on?
Wow.
He got in a room,
he got in a bar room argument in union city and he got arrested.
Over what,
uh,
probably politics.
I'm sure it was a political discussion.
Um,
so,
so then the,
the revolution happened and,
and you know,
uh,
Cuba becomes a repressive communist Stalinist dictatorship,
but a lot of Cubans,
the way they saw it is that was the choice they made to go with Fidel.
He did have a,
I think the,
the popularity of the people following of the people.
Some people are quite proud of Castro standing up to the United States.
Uh,
Cubans are very proud people and they take a lot of pride in the fact that even
though there's so much hardship there that um,
it's a choice they made to go in this direction.
At least they have.
There is self pride,
uh,
which is,
um,
more in the can be said in some ways about Puerto Rico and Jamaica and Dominican
Republic.
All these other countries in that region that are just as poor is Cuba.
Um,
so he has his supporters.
He always had his support.
Obviously.
He also had his detractors even within Cuba.
Um,
most of those people are the ones who got on rafts and tried to leave the island
at great risk to themselves to do anything to get out of there because they
realize Fidel was so popular from within the country.
You are never going to be able to take him down.
So they made the decision to go out in the ocean and try to brave the,
the risks of,
of either swimming or sailing across the Florida Strait.
Yeah.